الجمهور متشوق لمعرفه تفاصيل اكثر وقائمه
مسلسلات رمضان 2023 التي تنوعت بين دراما
الخليجيه والمصريه والسوريه واللبنانيه
وغيرها من الاعمال
ومن اهم هذه الاعمال المصريه مسلسل تحت
الوصايه الذي استطاع ان يحدث الجدل بمجرد
عرض ملصق ادعائي للمسلسل وانهارت حينها
الانتقادات على بطله المسلسل منى زكي
باعتبارها تسيء للمحجبات
احدث احداث المسلسل تدور في اطار درامي
حول سيدات تنفق على اسرتها من خلال عملها
على مركب صيد وتواجه عله الاسره العديد من
الخلافات والمشاكل التي تسعى لحلها الكبير
قوي يعود من جديد لينافس في قائمه مسلسلات
رمضان 2023 ايضا بموسه به السابع هذه
المره
تدور احداث المسلسل في اطار كوميدي حول
شخصيه الكبير وموقفها مع ابناء قريه
المزاريط وتعود معه مربوحه ايضا الشخصيه
التي لاقت اعجاب الجماهير في الموسم
السابق وهو من بطوله احمد مكي رحمه احمد
فرج بيومي فؤاد هشام اسماعيل محمد سلام
حسين ابو الحجاج
دنيا مش رومانسيه
عنها شويه
عايزه اكمل الحكايه للاخر دي حلوت
كلميني على المشروع عندنا مزرعه صغيره كده
نعمل فيها طبيعيه واعشاب
[موسيقى]
ومن الاعمال الخليجيه المنتظره في هذا
الموسم الرمضاني والتي عادت بعد غياب
مسلسل
الذي يتكون من عشرين حلقه ويعتمد في كل
حلقه على حكايه جديده يعد المسلسل من اشهر
المسلسلات السعوديه والخليجيه وحتى
العربيه بدا انتاج عام 1992 حيث تم تقديم
18 جزء من المسلسل بسبب نجاحه غير المسبوق
عربيا وعرض الجزء رقم 18 سنه 2011 ثم توقف
بعدها ليعود هذا العام تدور احداث طاش في
اطار جوني كوميدي حول عدد قضايا ومشاكل
المجتمع السعودي بشكل خاص وهو بالطبع من
بطوله ناصر القصبي عبد الله السدحان يوسف
الجراح فهد الحيان ريماس منصور وريم عبد
الله وغيرهم الكثير
انا حبيتك عشانك انت
[تصفيق]
رجعنا معاكم من جديد مشاهدينا الكرام
[موسيقى]
هذولا 36 سنه الله يعينك
ومن الاعماد رميه السوريه التي ينتظرها
الجمهور العربي بشغف في رمضان 2023 مسلسل
مربى العز الذي يناقش قضيه الاخلاق في
المجتمع ويلقي الضوء على التحولات الغريبه
التي طرات على منظومه القيم والاخلاق ايضا
مسلسل النار بالنار ينافس ضمن قائمه
مسلسلات رمضان 2023 الذي يعرض على منصه
شاهد وتدور احداث العمل في حاره صغيره
والتناول احداث موضوع العنصريه بشكل جريء
وهو من بطوله عابد فهد كاريس بشار جورج
خباز طوني عيسى دينامكي وتعرف تميم